- We found an image though of it,
it's of the school newspaper
that interviewed you
and, "I think a good comedian,"
that's what you said,
"should be able to relate to the audience
and talk about things in a
natural way," like you just did.
So you still believe this?
You're still rolling with...
You're rocking with this.
- Where did you find that?
(audience laughing)
- Last night I snuck into your house-
- (gasps) No, no!
- I'm just kidding.
- No, wait!
Yo, I don't even have this.
That's crazy, I said that?
- Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
But you know what I think is beautiful?
It's somebody in this audience,
including myself, needed
to hear exactly what you just said.
But I think,
(audience applauding)
I think what's incredible
is you said this a long time ago,
but you're still living that same truth.
You're still living those same words,
which is kind of incredible,
so we're gonna be best friends.
- Because that's what, that's...
(Kelly chuckling)
Man.
- Be my best friend, okay.
(audience laughing)
- That, that, it just makes, ooh.
- [Audience] Aaw.
(audience applauding)
- Do you remember that moment
though, like being apart?
It couldn't have been easy the whole time.
You had to bomb once, right?
(audience laughing)
- You're wrong.
- Take a minute.
(Leslie and audience laughing)
Did I just Oprah you?
- Yes, you just Oprahed me.
- I was like, I didn't even mean to.
No, I just think it's
a beautiful thing how,
(audience laughing)
it's a beautiful thing like how, you know,
you find these things
from when you were younger
and that dreamer and then,
you didn't lose that.
That essence is still
in you, that's awesome.
We're gonna get you a
photocopy of this, okay?
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
I'm gonna have it like...
Aaw.
(audience applauding)
Why are you so moved right now?
I need to know exactly why.
- 'Cause I didn't think I was that smart.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- You are-
- Not then, not then.
I was a wreck, I was a mess.
- Maybe you thought you were a mess.
Maybe you were living
in that-
- I was a 19-year-old mess.
- We all were!
What 19-year-old has
their (beep) together?
(audience laughing)
Nobody knows (beep) at 19.
- I done messed up my makeup.
- You can't air any
of that, sorry.
- Lord, have mercy!
I came out here to be beautiful.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
- Okay, wait.
We're gonna get touched up
(Leslie screaming)
in a commercial break, Leslie's book-
- We gotta get my makeup girl out here!
- Leslie, Lolo!
- Lolo!
- Mine's Glowgo, that's so funny.
Leslie's book is called
"Leslie bleeping Jones,"
it's out now.
You gotta go get it,
it's gonna change your life!
- Oh my God.